it's not a fucking
look if you're gonna robust me just do
it now amy did you understand all those
instructions yes i did but this is
ridiculous do you have any questions
regarding this exercise
i already told those people that i would
pay for all of them
so
do you have any questions regarding this
exercise
because i already know
if you understood all those instructions
you don't have any questions regarding
the exercise you may get in that
starting position
and then you made it
have you completed that exercise
so next exercise is what's called a one
leg step
so i'm gonna have you stand
up
my
my fucking ballet coach
is
[Music]
any questions
any
are you gonna do
exercise
[Music]
do you understand
[Music]
i have no idea
it is safe for me i just want to go home
please
do you want to do this last exercise
it's just the other day well if you
want your home
it's not a bargain anymore
you
that wasn't the exercise
um
all right
do not pull away you understand
please
oh god